[Music]
the next step is
using small light autonomous machines
so robots small robots that do the same
work but then another man on it you need
a farmer for the decisions
but you for the most of the labor you
don't need the farmer anymore and then
you could don't need again this big
very big machine
one example that's already available is
that we have uh this
small machine for spraying actually
there are
two big solar panels it's a very light
machine it recognizes a weed and it puts
a little drop of pesticide
on a wheat
and it makes
a difference of let's say 95 reduction
in herbicide use
so if you can reduce that herbicide use
with 95 then maybe herbicides are not
such a problem anymore because you use
so little
so but also for diseases and spraying
now we spray everything the same
while only that plant and that plant and
that plant is ill but we do everything
we're using a cannon to kill a mosquito
if we are able to recognize the first
spot
of
the disease or who can find the pests or
we can find the wheat we can you do it
very precisely and it means that we can
at least reduce pesticides use
20-fold
the way we're doing producing now our
food is not very future proof we're
doing agriculture
in big monocultures
five ten twenty hundred hectares of
exactly the same everywhere
and it's the same as covet 19 if you put
a lot of
genetically exactly the same individuals
close together
then a pest and disease spreads very
quickly the main points in the
agroecological approach
are that we have a focus on soil
management and we have a focus on crop
diversity crop diversity and time like
rotation
but also crop diversity in space and
that is mixed cropping strip cropping or
whatever
[Music]